do you want a nintendo switch but can't
seem to find one well it sounds like
Nintendo was responding to the lack of
stock by doubling the production of its
new console I'm Matt this is a game spot
news update and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe for all the news about the
switch as it's announced according to
The Wall Street Journal Nintendo planned
to manufacture 8 million consoles by the
end of March but the company has since
doubled that number to at least 16
million we don't have official sales
numbers yet but Nintendo has announced
the switches its fastest selling console
ever in the Americas Europe and
Australia one report even said that
about 1.5 million switch units were sold
in its first week that means it's almost
met Nintendo's first month expectations
of 2 million sales as you can probably
expect the high demand has caused the
switch in its flagship games out of
breath of the wild to run out of stock
at many major retailers if you want to
stay up to date on when stock is
projected to hit certain stores stay
tuned to gamespot com and if you want to
get ready for when you do have a switch
check out our video on the nine things
we wish we knew before starting breath
of the wild
[Music]